trois morts dans cette fin
d'entraînement de montréal on s'apprête
à fermer les portes pour une troisième
fois
quelques semaines à peine après les
avoir ouverte lors de tout arrêter
on doit absolument tout arrêté puis
repartir de zéro et ses maps à zéro ses
rentes sous zéro lag à chaque fois il
faut remonter il faut aller chercher de
nouveaux clients
les gens en ont marre québec annonce une
nouvelle fermeture des djembés des
salles de sports intérieurs en zone
rouge dès jeudi le propriétaire gunness
orma ne sait plus sur quel pied danser
on aurait souhaité en faire ne pas
réouvrir dans le fond on se dit qu'il
aurait été mieux de rester je veux dire
avec ce premier enfin ce deuxième coup
qu'on a eu depuis resté comme ça jusqu'à
que cette affaire soit réglée une fois
pour toutes au moins on n'a pas ce faux
espoirs il n'est pas le seul à être
excédés dans la rue bien des citoyens se
demandent à quoi joue le gouvernement
ça fait quoi de ces mêmes qui avaient
annoncé qu'ils seraient ouverts que ça
horrible ça fait je pensais c'est
difficile pour la morale des gens moi je
vraiment mais françois legault l'admet
lui même la situation demeure maîtriser
pour l'instant il choisit néanmoins de
restreindre à nouveau les libertés des
québécois de façon préventive
si on regarde ce qui se passe ailleurs
en particulier en ontario on se dit que
c'est probablement une question de jours
aux questions maximum deux semaines
oui pour l'instant on a résisté un peu
plus longtemps
caillard à la fermeture des jim
s'ajoutent de nouvelles restrictions
pour les lieux de culte qui ne pourront
accueillir plus de 25 personnes en zone
rouge
et même s'ils ont repris les cours à
temps plein en chair et en os
il y a à peine une semaine les élèves de
3e 4e et 5e secondaire en zone rouge
reprendront l'enseignement à distance un
jour sur deux dès la semaine prochaine
plutôt que d'être en tête et puis non je
me contredirait pas et on s'ajuste selon
l'évolution en trop des variants puis
ben temps nu si on a eu une semaine de
plus en zone orange ou si des mesures
s'ajoutent les élèves du primaire
devront tous obligatoirement porter le
masque et la capacité d'accueil des
lieux cultes sera limitée à 100
personnes
la santé publique se défend d'avoir
procédé à des assouplissements
trop hâtif au québec nos mesures sont un
mal plus sévère qu'ailleurs le registre
clair avec seul
on a l'impression qu'on ne beaucoup
allégé mais dans les fêtes nous on un
couvre feu ce qui n'existe pas ailleurs
on a interdit les rassemblements à
l'intérieur ces annonces ne changeront
pas grand chose aux zones déjà touchées
de mesure spéciale d'urgence comme
québec lévis et gatineau ailleurs de
nouvelles contraintes pourraient
s'ajouter comme un retour potentiel du
couvre feu dès 20h tout dépendra du
nombre d'hospitalisations et de patients
en soins intensifs
ici hugo lavallée radio canada québec